right there's my trout graph part 4 now
actually starts to ask about this other
fish that's in here right it says when
is the rate of increase of carp equal to
the rate of decrease of trout hmm now
just put your pen down for a minute and
feed this is one of those very very rare
cases where they give you a differential
equation they cop right but then they
don't actually give you the actual
equation for carp and then say now just
prove that this satisfies blah blah blah
you actually have to work that bit out
okay so we're going to have to have two
piece of information here right it says
when is the rate of increase of carp so
carp is pee right did I write that
no I didn't maybe you wrote down carp is
P so the rate of increase of carp
is going to be DP on DT right that's the
rate of increase of the cop okay
the trout though are decreasing okay so
here's the number of trout what's the
rate of decrease of the trout okay so
I'm going to get a derivative out of
this right DM on DT because they're
decreasing this will be negative yeah
but I want to know when the right here
and the red there match if that's
positive all the time because they do
any pick up and this is negative all the
time when are they going to be equal if
one thing is always positive and the
other thing is always negative the
answer is they never occupy the same
space so these two numbers are never
going to be equal but the rates being
equal means that this will be equal does
that make sense because you're just
taking the rate and you're saying well
turn it upside down you have the same
number you know trout per month and cop
per month does that make sense now D NR
DT we can work that out quite easily
because we have an so can you help me
work out what DN on DT is have a look
there it is
negative 0.04 that's come from the
inside function of chain rule and then
the a to the blah blah blah blah blah
that's all still the same there's the N
or DT okay now we have an expression V D
for D pay on DT but it's not very useful
right have a look let's write it there
zero point zero to P this is the
differential equation okay now why is
this not very useful
I don't know what P is right and also
I'm trying to find out the question look
really carefully right what is the
actual question asking for what's the
answer like my final line is going to be
is it a number of trout a number of carp
what's the question asking it's asking
for a time now this is in terms of time
thumbs up but this is not in terms of
time it's in terms of the population
right so I need to go from this equation
to one where it is in terms of time then
I can combine these two together and
then I can solve so you need an equation
for this in terms of time you're going
to have to begin with the equation for
this in terms of time and they don't
tell you what it is okay now what topic
are we in exponential growth and decay
right there it is so I know and it's to
unit I know every exponential growth and
decay situation is going to have a very
similar kind of form a similar kind of
equation it's going to look a lot like
that one right is it increasing or
decreasing
this is carp right it's increasing so
there's some I don't think I've used
capital a yet there's some value you
start with and then it increases
according to my growth rate okay now you
can go ahead and if you're like where
did that come from well remember you
start with equations like this and then
you have to differentiate to get to that
see with that 0.02 comes from it comes
from the same place that this 0.04 came
from from that index okay so you can go
ahead you can differentiate you can
prove to yourself that you get back to
that this is still not enough it's still
not enough because I don't know what a
is right so how do I
find out what a is I need some kind of
condition thankfully I do know how many
cough there were at time zero have it
look happy there were 10 right so I can
say when T equals zero
initially there were 10 carp that they
put into the lake because they wanted to
get rid of all the trap I don't know so
I can substitute all of those things in
and quickly you get an equation right
which by the way sometimes you'll even
see the question will not call this a
it'll call it something like p 0 p
naught to indicate in this model that's
the population in at time 0 okay all
right
at last I now actually can take this and
get a DP on DT out of it if P is this
can you please differentiate for me that
tell me what you get for DP or duty
I'll give you a spoiler warning
it starts with zero point what someone
got for me zero point two so watch out
for those decimal places right that 10
hanging out the front multiply by zero
point zero two gives you that and this
is still here you could have also done
that from here as well okay all right so
now I've got these two rates so I can
say excuse me
the rates equal the rates equal where
and I've got this right here when I slap
a minus sign on the front that just
gives me the absolute value of that so
zero point zero four e to the that
equals zero point two into the that
please please please watch out for all
of your decimal points you can come up
with a very nonsensical answer just by
for example writing zero point two here
and forgetting that that's zero point
zero two it's a different number has
come from the derivative so you can go
ahead what will be a sensible thing to
do first out of this to simplify
when were you're teasing one spot right
there currently into what operation
should I do to get them into one spot
think what operation am I going to apply
to both sides I I could take the log
first if I wanted but I think it makes
sense to have one or have I done
something wrong
yeah you mean here no think carefully
what am I asking for right why is there
not a negative here it's because this
rate of increase sorry this is a
decrease actually should match this rate
of increase right if I had a minus sign
here you know when you're gonna get an
answer answer you are never going to get
an answer they will never meet okay
but actually I want to compare when
their values their magnitudes are the
same so I actually can ignore all the
sign if that makes sense
I'll take me absolute value if you like
great you can go ahead if you pop the
minus sign here
go and get nuts ah and you'll find no
real solution okay all right can someone
suggest to me what to do
I'm just I'm still thinking about what
might be an appropriate thing to apply
the both sides if I gave you this hmm
what would you do to that would that be
simpler if I gave you that if you want
you're solving for T right what you can
do to that you should divide both sides
by you'd probably choose this right
because it's the smaller one right
that's what when you know normally do so
I want you to have a look at me here
which one is the smaller one it's this
guy isn't it so I'm going to divide both
sides by that okay I guess at the same
time I might as well deal with these
constants okay once you've gone through
you should get a time once you get a
taylean to talk okay